for the last three years Russian sport
has been firmly sidelined as accusations
mounted over state-sponsored doping
[Music]
the media has been in meltdown the BBC
sports editor Dan Rowan tweeted out what
he claimed was a letter from wadis
compliance review committee saying Russ
Aris prolonged suspension was already a
done deal let's take a look at the whole
picture
just hours after owns report water
published an official statement
rubbishing these notions the world
anti-doping agency's independent
compliance review committee delivered a
recommendation for the Reign statement
of the Russian anti-doping agency wada
also admitted it does not reveal
information like that too often but it
did so this time to put any speculation
to bed it also openly said that the 31
conditions it had put forward to resada
two years ago for reinstatement have
been met conditions which included
allowing UK anti-doping experts into
Russian labs to provide training
replacing the personnel monthly orders
by wada among others with the two most
contentious ones acknowledging the
findings of the mclaren report and
granting unconditional access to urine
samples in russian laboratories which
have been under federal investigation
there those remained in limbo up until
last week rolling forward a bit and the
BBC then publishes a letter from the
Russian Sports Minister to water where
he agreed to all the demands and hoped
that the world body would reinstate
rusada
so if that's the case and Russia has
ticked off all the criteria why is
everyone so mad I want to make sure this
statement that they've attached over the
last three years sticks
even though Russia will be allowed back
into sport they want to make sure that
every time any commentator anywhere in
the world mentions a Russian athlete
they say that they'd served three years
in exile because of doping violations
and then want to emphasize that point to
advertise to the rest of the world how
tough water is and how difficult it can
be to get round kind of the doping
regulations in reality of course every
sporting nation on the planet is
engaged in some kind of doping violation
it's just that they've been a bit
cleverer about it the Russia or that
Russia has simply been singled out as a
kind of scapegoat and people are
quitting their jobs because of it namely
Becky Scott a retired Olympic champion
in cross-country skiing who stepped down
from the review panel after its
recommendation to wada
the possibility of Russia coming in from
the cold is dividing the world
anti-doping agency its vice president
says she will vote against the
reinstatement and she's being backed by
Australia Canada the United Kingdom the
USA and New Zealand who are all urging
the agency's president to reconsider
if you choose to reinstate Russia you
defied the very wish of the athletes
committees and organizations around the
world have very clearly stated they will
not accept a reinstatement now the
sporting community around the world has
spoken and the message is consistent and
clear rusada cannot be declared
compliant until all outstanding
conditions set out in the roadmap have
been satisfied we believe that any
compromises to the roadmap will tarnish
waters reputation and bring global sport
into disrepute essentially rosado's
revival is not set in stone and it could
mean thousands of clean athletes in
Russia will be hitting the first hurdle
when it comes to entering competitions
all over again with their respective
Federation's hands tied until Rosario
resumes its normal operations so will
Thursday's decision by wada be
influenced by sport politics or common
sense
you